哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天要進入的主題呢
是有一點時間沒有跟大家分享的放心來信
那這一次放心來信的主題呢
因為有很多媽媽
分享就是自己身為媽媽的一些壓力啊
還有養育小孩的一些心情
所以今天的主題呢
是關於這些媽媽們的一些心情分享
那首先第一位媽媽分享說
我是一位媽媽
因為凡事比較悲觀也容易情緒化
遇到生活育兒的壓力會想要躲起來
什麼事都不管
但又不行
於是就容易覺得痛苦
我喜歡滑手機
小孩常常跟我說他很無聊
我卻一點也不想跟他們玩
被晾在旁邊
只喜歡看電視
跟我想像希望他們自信開朗
興趣很多或是喜歡戶外活動
都完全不一樣
我很不會養小孩
甚至覺得幹嘛生小孩
如果知道生小孩要負擔這麼大的責任
當初就不生了
我對自己不滿意
自己喜歡滑手機
卻希望小孩喜歡戶外活動
我自己很悲觀
卻希望小孩正面積極
生活在城市卻希望搬到鄉下
讓小孩自由自在的生活
但因為就學
我又做不到
甚至覺得小孩如果給別人養
會不會好一點
我沒有辦法給他們正確的良好的價值觀
我自己很糟
希望小孩不要跟我一樣
但發現他們跟我越來越像
我不知道怎麼逃脫這樣的想法
希望慕姿老師可以給我一些意見
好 這位媽媽
我覺得
對妳來說最大的困難
可能是生活真的好多好多
就是妳需要處理跟期待的事情
我可以感覺到妳對自己的期待很高
對小孩的期待也很高
妳會希望能夠給他們比較好的生活
能夠讓他們成為比較好的人
但是卻發現這件事情好不容易
因為妳連自己都好難照顧好
其實我有的時候覺得
身為一個媽媽是很辛苦的
因為當妳好像就是在為這個社會做志工
每個人對妳都有期待
每個人都希望妳可以做到最好
我們也這樣期待自己的時候
對於日常生活就很難不悲觀啊
所以當妳提到說妳比較悲觀
比較情緒化
我有的時候就在想
妳對自己應該也是一個相對嚴格的人
所以才會比較容易把事情想的比較悲觀
但並不是因為妳比較悲觀
而是因為
如果妳需要未雨綢繆想很多可能性的話
這個狀態本來就會變得比較悲觀
因此它不是一個
好像就是我悲觀是我不好
而是那是一個個性的特質
那就是對妳來說
也許妳會比較習慣
希望先把一些事情先想好
後果先把它預期好
於是當妳想了太多不好的後果的時候
當然就會比較容易悲觀
與其說我能給妳什麼意見
我還覺得
妳能夠在這個生活撐下去其實很不簡單哦
所以我覺得我好像也沒有什麼
了不起的意見可以給妳
但是如果妳真要問我的看法
我反而會覺得
如果妳能夠知道
妳現在的狀態是一個很必然的結果
那並不是因為妳不夠努力
並不是因為妳很糟
而是妳現在遇到的生活考驗跟困難的確很高
而且聽起來就是
妳會認為小孩變成怎麼樣好像都是妳的關係
但是小孩他遇到的大人可能不只是妳
所以我也很好奇妳的生活有沒有援手呢
有沒有人可以幫助妳呢
在妳沒有力氣可以就是
帶領他們去探索戶外的時候
有沒有別人可以做這樣的事情呢
所以當我們必須把小孩的
狀況跟責任都放在自己身上的時候
那要背負另外一個生命的重量
真的是很不容易的事
所以我反而會更鼓勵妳
了解妳現在在背負的責任跟重量
真的是重的
然後做妳能做的事情就好
如果做什麼樣的事情
有開始做一點點
就會讓妳對自己的感受好一些
我們就試著去做做看
先不要把注意力放在妳做不到的事情上
而是先把注意力放在
可能妳做的到改變一點點的事情上
然後好好的去感受這個改變對妳產生的意義
我想也許對妳的生活會有一點點幫助
也會給妳一點點的力量
再來是 N 小姐的來信
最近很內耗 在工作與家庭之間
我選擇一份有彈性但可以兼顧小孩的工作
前陣子被主管PUA
突然一瞬間被打擊
因為前幾年工作很認真
我以為會被看見並被記得
但自從被PUA之後我就一蹶不振
有很想離開的感覺
就想起自己原生家庭也是這麼對待我
沒有讚美只有不停的做
但讓我最擔心的不是要不要離職
而是我發現
最近我5歲的兒子也有相同的問題
當我稱讚姐姐或是他人
兒子就會否定自己
說那是不是他就不可愛不好
很擔心自己把原生家庭那一部分
無形之中給了我的孩子
想問是不是應該帶孩子去諮商
好 N小姐
我只能說妳真的是一個對自我覺察很高的人
然後很快的就發現
孩子有這樣的狀況
我能夠為他做一些怎麼樣的調整
我覺得這個是一件很棒的事情哦
不過我覺得有一個蠻有趣的地方是
如果孩子跟媽媽或是跟爸爸的感情很好的時候
有的時候呢
爸爸媽媽的情緒的確會比較容易
就是小孩會跟著被影響
可是那不代表就是那是爸爸媽媽的錯
那是因為你們感情很好
情緒就很容易經驗共享
這是很正常的
因此在這樣的狀況
我反而會更鼓勵妳
如果妳可以把妳自己的狀態穩定好
我想對孩子會很有幫助
因為如果妳把妳的情緒穩定好
妳能夠理解妳今天被不公平對待
對方不合理的評價妳
妳可以慢慢去建立屬於妳自己的價值
以及妳對每件事情
妳認為的行為標準是什麼
妳能夠越堅定的時候
面對小孩有這個反應的時候
妳其實比較有力氣可以去回應跟安撫
當他跟妳說
妳稱讚姐姐是不是我不好了
妳就跟他說
姐姐很好
你也可以很好啊
今天姐姐很好不代表你不好啊
你怎麼會這麼想呢
所以你們可以一起很好
當妳可以這麼堅定的告訴他的時候
他就會慢慢的去調整他的認知
因為小孩都是從大人的回應中
去理解這個世界的
因此我在想
或許妳不一定需要非常非常的擔心
可是我在想
妳可能要多花一點時間好好照顧自己
看到自己被虧待了
好好安慰自己受傷的心
也跟自己說
我真的很努力
我非常棒
即使這個努力不一定會被別人肯定
也有可能別人不肯定我是故意的哦
因為他不肯定我我就會做更多
這也是有可能的
所以
不要讓自己
把自己的價值放在別人的肯定當中
這件事情
會讓我們比較不容易被利用或是被傷害
因為如果我自己能夠清楚
做什麼東西對我是重要的
我就能夠更容易做出屬於我自己的選擇
而我的情緒穩定度就會更高
面對小孩在
比較就是不確定或是自我認知不穩定的時候
我也比較能夠堅定的回應他
這對小孩也是一個很棒的事情
因此跟妳分享
接下來是阿姿
慕姿老師你好
一路與原生家庭創傷共存
直到步入婚姻再成為媽媽
小孩在學校發生諸多偏差行為
剖析後發現源頭是自己內心創傷未解決
所以展開心理治療
好幾次想把內心痛苦都傾吐給原生家庭
又擔心造成彼此負擔
請問慕姿老師這方式合適嗎
有需要讓原生家庭知道
原來我是帶著創傷成長的嗎
好 阿姿
這個事情
你問的這個問題
其實很多人都想要問的問題
那就是如果我發現
原生家庭養育我的方式造成了我一些創傷
那麼我要不要回過頭去
跟造成我創傷源頭的人
去告訴他都是你害的
都是你讓我有那麼大的創傷
然後這樣子能夠讓我比較好嗎
我覺得這件事情
它必須回到一個非常重要關鍵
因為妳有在做心理治療
所以我會蠻鼓勵妳
可以跟妳的心理師討論這個部分
不過回到如果是一般的狀況
我反而會覺得
我們需要問問自己
我做這件事情的目的是什麼
如果純粹是在情緒上的傾訴
那我們就要確定
對方給我的回應是我承受的住的
也就是說
如果今天我感受到這一些創傷
我想要去跟對方說
只是因為我想要傾洩我的情緒
可是對方的回應很有可能讓我們更傷心
對方有可能不一定承受的住這些
因為去做心理治療的是妳不是他們
所以他們可能跟妳的
就是自我了解的程度完全是不一樣的
跟妳的覺察是不一樣的
跟妳的情緒成熟度是不一樣的
因此他不一定承接的住
妳丟下來的這些東西
原本妳期望可以被接住
於是這個創傷能夠慢慢變好
可是當它沒有辦法的時候
妳可能會更受傷
可是我完全可以理解
有時候我們會很想要回過頭
去跟原生家庭做這個傾訴的原因
是因為我真的好希望我的痛你可以看到
你可以理解我
這個是無可厚非的
所以如果真的要做這件事情
一定要有心理準備
而且一定要有確定
妳的家人是能夠承受得起這一切的
否則對妳來說可能會是二次傷害
當然對某些人來說
我更在乎的可能只是對方能夠知道這件事情
但是他能不能理解
他的回應我都不在乎
他也不會傷害我
如果是這樣
或許這就是某個可以選擇的做法
但是我想
如果我們會回過頭
想要去跟自己的原生家庭討論這件事情的時候
有些時候其實是很需要對方的回應的
因此對方有沒有能力給我們這個回應
就會變成是一個很需要小心評估的狀態
我現在在說的就是
不一定能或不一定不能
但是這個部分
第一 妳一定要跟你的心理師討論
第二 妳要有一些比較安全的評估
讓妳自己
就是我最喜歡講的一句話
先講究不傷身體
再講究療效
了解妳要回頭去跟這一些原生家庭講這些事情
妳想要達到的目的是什麼
評估妳想要達到這個目的
他們能不能做得到
會決定妳要不要做這件事情
而我認為在創傷的這一個療癒的過程
最大最大的困難真的是
我們要怎麼樣能夠接受我們所期待的父母
他們可能永遠做不到我們想要的事
我們接受
這就是我們經歷到的原生家庭的狀態
他們可能永遠都沒有辦法像我們想要的愛我們
像我們想要的給我們我們想要的東西
他們可能在某些事情的能力是好的
但在這方面的能力就是不好的
他們可能就是沒有把我們看的那麼重要
可能就是沒有那麼愛我們
可能他有其他更重要的事情
可能真的是這樣
我們要怎麼樣可以消化這樣的失落
我們要能夠理解這樣被對待的自己
然後跟自己說
我知道我遭遇了這個
這個就是我誠實面對的現在
可是現在的我可以好好的對待自己
讓自己有不同的感受跟經驗
我可以看到以前自己被虧待的樣子
然後現在的我可以好好的照顧自己
我願意給自己這樣的機會
我在想
或許這也是一個可以思考的方式
跟妳分享
再來有一位
嗨慕姿
讀了幾頁妳的親密恐懼
讓我更不害怕看見這樣的自己
我覺得臺灣的父母太少跟孩子談情說愛
我自己就是在這樣的環境中長大的
但我又非常渴望有同齡伴侶的角色能夠理解我
讓我學習什麼是愛
而我又更明白
身為一個能夠表達愛的家長有多麼重要
可是覺得自己沒法做到
因而對孩子養育這塊很恐懼卻步
光想到孕育孩子的過程
會失去各種
像是身體的自主權
工作的中斷
產後的恢復
接下來還要對這個生命負責至少20年
總覺得整個過程是消耗我的
其實這樣我就更拿不出愛來養育了
很希望自己可以找到育兒的意義
也做過不少嘗試
努力去跟周邊的孩子互動
但真的沒有燃起愛的火花
又不想走一步算一步
請問慕姿老師有什麼回饋可以協助我嗎
我覺得妳的問題很有趣
就是有些人也許跟妳一樣
她就不一定會生小孩
就是也許她的注意力或是她在乎的事情
更在她自己的
就是自我成長跟她自己的生命裡面
可是看起來就是
妳既希望能夠在妳自己的身上多花點時間
但另外個部分
好像育兒對妳來說又是一件很重要的事情
所以妳需要找到意義
所以我反而會覺得這件事情比較有趣的是
不知道是不是因為
對妳來說
現在可能已經懷孕了或是已經有小孩了
不過我覺得
能夠跟一個生命跟另外一個人可以建立起關係
其實是一件很不容易的事情
某方面也是緣分
我們當然可以不用花時間去跟對方建立關係
去照顧對方
去在別人的生命裡就是占有一席之地
我們可以不需要做這些事情
我們可以只照顧自己
可是我發現人在活在這個世界上
生命最有意義的事情
有時候不只是你做到了什麼
而是你犧牲了什麼
如果你今天看懂了很多
很多你在裡面做的選擇
會發生的犧牲
而你還是願意做這個選擇
我有時候覺得這件事情就代表著
你知道了
你也標記了這件事情對你有多重要
而我能夠承認這是我自己的選擇
這件事情就是很重要的
因此要不要生小孩
育不育兒
這個東西的意義
我在想
可能沒有任何人可以幫妳找到答案
為什麼妳想要生小孩
為什麼不想
為什麼妳很重視自我的身體的自主權
妳還是願意為了孩子做一些放棄跟犧牲
為什麼妳很重視你個人的成長
卻還是願意把妳的時間送給孩子
我想這一些選擇中
都會為我們帶來一些意義
因此這個意義
我在想最終還是必須回到妳自己
我自己為什麼要做這樣的選擇
這對我帶來的影響
跟對我的意義是什麼呢
我覺得也許妳可以好好的問問自己
好 今天回答了四個故事
我覺得媽媽是一個很不容易的角色
自己內心的掙扎
社會的期待
自我的期待
他人的期待
媽媽或許是最難逃離這個期待的部分
在這期待中
有時候我會有我自己想要看重的事情
可是當外面的世界
要求我必須給這個孩子很多很多的愛的時候
我感覺到自己的有限
我反而就會害怕我是不是不夠愛
可是有的時候也許不是因為妳不夠愛
有的時候是因為
這個世界要求妳愛的太多
可是當我們願意為這個孩子付出一些努力
付出一些犧牲
付出一些我自己
我在想
那就是妳愛的證明
今天跟大家分享放心來信
周慕姿放心說
我們下次見
掰掰